foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday November 11th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
it has been an incredibly bumpy ride for
crypto firms this year
as the prices of crypto have fallen some
big names in the industry have collapsed
for a while one Bastion of stability for
the industry was Sam bankman freed
founder of the cryptocurrency exchange
FTX
he kept a positive outlook for the
sector and even bought up large stakes
in struggling businesses like crypto
lender blockify and Voyager digital just
a few weeks ago bankman freed talked
about possible future funding deals and
Acquisitions that FTX might make at the
wsj's tech live conference I'm
optimistic that that you know the
funding is
um that it it's you know of strategic
importance for us and I think I think it
might be I think that you know in this
market there are a lot of opportunities
that we're seeing the types of
opportunities that we did not see last
year
um to uh make you know really efficient
Acquisitions that can help grow out what
we can do as a business that all changed
this week facing a liquidity crisis FTX
froze customers withdrawals and agreed
to be purchased by rival crypto Exchange
binance
but just a day later binance pulled out
citing concerns that came up during its
due diligence of FTX then on Friday FTX
filed for bankruptcy protection and
bankman freed stepped down as CEO
so how did things get to this point and
how could this whole Saga affect the
wider crypto space
joining us to discuss all of that is wsj
crypto reporter Vicki Huang hi Vicki
thanks for joining me thank you for
having me Zoe
can you start by reminding us what FTX
is and how it became so big in the
crypto space
so FDX is one of the largest crypto
exchanges in the industry and it was
actually founded just three years ago
and it just grew really rapidly because
of its very up until this week
charismatic founder Sam Beckman freed so
the exchange focused a lot on
derivatives and one of their taglines is
that FTX is an exchange build for
Traders by Traders it also benefited
from the fact that it's based offshore
first in Hong Kong and then in the
Bahamas so it was able to grow in an
environment where sort of there's less
regulatory restrictions you know as you
say sam bankman freed or SBF is he
sometimes called by crypto fans he
really built this company this crypto
exchange into something that was very
popular and very valuable so take us
back how did it get into the situation
that it is now so in January ftx's last
founding wrong the crypto exchange was
valued at 32 billion and the
participating investors were basically a
who's who of VCS and hedge funds and
prominent private equity and even
pension investors and it really looked
Untouchable because of the marketing
that the exchange has done as well as
the reputation of San Batman free as
sort of one of the smartest crypto
traders that is also lobbying in
Washington DC and Brandon himself as an
effective altruist and is a vegan
because of his concern for Animal
Welfare but what's underneath all this
glamor and success is his other firm
Alameda research a trading firm he
founded in 2017. Alameda research
is supposed to be a market maker that
provides liquidity to crypto exchanges
but because both Alameda research and
FTX are majority owned by Sam Batman
freeze there has been a lot of
skepticism and doubts about the
relationship between the two firms
people were worried that whether Alameda
research was getting preferential
treatment
FTX or whether the phones between the
two companies are commingled or separate
and then last week we had this coindust
report that showed us the balance sheet
of Alameda research as of June 30th
was made up mostly of a token called ftt
token which is issued by FTX
and that report just
sort of showed the close relationship
between the two companies and cutting to
doubt the
Financial strengths of Alameda research
because why is such a supposedly
powerful trading firm would have so much
of this ftt token which is itself a
highly illiquid token on its balance
sheet so how did investors react when
that report came out when the report
first came out investor reactions were
pretty muted there weren't a ton of
selling of ftt going on but that all
changed on Sunday when the CEO of
binance CZ shot for tampon Zhao tweeted
that he was going to sell
580 million worth of ftt tokens over the
coming months so cz's tweet set off a
chain reaction of events and before you
know it the price of ftt started
plunging rumors about the potential
insolvency of FTX started circulating
and Traders started withdrawing their
deposits from FTX on mass and background
free has came out and said that about 5
billion dollars worth of withdrawal took
place just over the past few days okay
so a massive liquidity crisis we're also
learning more about the relationship
between Alameda research and FTX what
more have we learned in the past couple
of days some really shocking facts about
close relationship between Alameda and
FTX even though Sam Batman freed or
Alameda research or FTX they haven't
come out and said anything or
acknowledge any of these but sources
have been telling us that FDX loaned
Alameda research billions of dollars
when some of Alameda researches
Investments went bad during the months
of crypto Market Carnage that we've had
since May so that really puts this whole
thing into question because as an
exchange you're supposed to segregate
customers deposits from your own money
but here it seems like that Sam could
potentially have sent users deposits
to Alameda research
and we've heard from sources that the
justice department and the Securities
and Exchange Commission have
investigations now into FTX have we
heard from Sam bankman freed FTX or
Alameda about this whole situation
yes he has expressed his remorse for
this whole situation he has apologized
to customers investors but he hasn't yet
really offered any details about what
went wrong or whether he sent money into
Alameda research who's going to feel the
Fallout from ftx's current crisis
unfortunately first of all it's always
going to be the retail investors who
trusted the exchange who trusted Sam
with their deposits So currently
withdrawals are passed on FTX the
International Exchange for a lot of
international crypto traders that I've
talked to they are feeling pretty
frustrated and disappointed they don't
expect to see their money ever again
and then another group of investors that
stand to be burned as a result of this
collapse of FTX our institutional
investors who invested in the various
rounds of FTX and a lot of them are
quite well-known Silicon Valley or Wall
Street players for example Sequoia
Capital has come out and said that they
would mark down their investment in FTX
2-0 so that's a complete Wipeout of
their investment a lot of people are
thinking that this so-called crypto
winter where prices remain depressed and
there is little to no trading volume is
going to perhaps last a lot longer than
they had expected and for the industry
it's overall it's a huge setback because
we're looking at increased regulatory
scrutiny and a lot of projects that are
in progress are likely to be delayed so
it's just a lot of negative consequences
for the players and in the space just so
much to break down here and so much to
keep watching Vicki Wong wsj crypto
reporter thank you so much for joining
us thank you so much for having me and
that's it for Tech news briefing this
week our producer is Julie Chang we had
editorial support from philana Patterson
our supervising producer is Chris
dinsley and I'm your host Zoe Thomas
Thanks so much for listening and have a
great weekend
[Music]
thank you